[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
der Verbrennermotor ist also ein
Auslaufmodell das wissen wir jetzt
sicher die 27
EU-Mitgliedstaaten und das Europäische
Parlament haben sich auf ein Verbot von
Neuwagen geeinigt die mit Diesel oder
Benzin betankt werden ab 2035 also in
gut zwölf Jahren Europa setzt auf
Elektrofahrzeuge ganz Europa nein die
deutsche Regierung hat auf Wunsch der
FDP noch ein Hintertürchen in den
Kompromiss hineinverhandelt in ein paar
Jahren soll er nochmal geprüft werden ob
der Verbrennermotor nicht auch mit
synthetischen Kraftstoffen weiterfahren
können wir sprechen gleich mit dem
Bundesverkehrsminister zunächst aber
berichtet Lothar Becker über das Auto
der Zukunft und raten Sie mal wo das
herkommt
so sieht sie aus die erste
Premium-Limousine aus China die seit
wenigen Tagen auch in Deutschland zu
haben ist der et7 von Neo anstatt nur zu
laden kann er als einziges Serienauto
einen leergefahrenen Akku komplett
austauschen innerhalb weniger Minuten
wir sind Überzeugung dass wir mit dem
Akku Tausch ein ganz großen Mehrwert
bieten das ist für uns sicherlich auch
ein USP also wir machen das anders als
andere und der Mehrwert liegt einfach
daran bedingt dass sie innerhalb von
fünf Minuten den Akku tauschen können
und nicht mehr um die 20 Minuten beim
Laden stehen müssen die Idee ist nicht
neu sondern 50 Jahre alt Mercedes-Benz
demonstrierte in einem Versuchsmodell
bereits 1972 dass der Akkutausch möglich
ist und langes Warten beim Laden unnötig
in den 1990ern gab es verschiedenste
Hybrid und vollelektrische
Versuchsfahrzeuge made in Germany
in den 2000ern wurde in Japan erneut an
der wechselbatterie geforscht auch
Renault beteiligte sich an der Vision
vom schnell geladenen E-Auto forschen ja
gerne doch Serienproduktion nein danke
in diese Zurückhaltung drängten neue
Marken allen voran Tesla lange belächelt
inzwischen der mit Abstand stärkste
e-auto-produzent weltweit auch weil der
Hersteller früh in eine eigene
schnellladeinfrastruktur investiert hat
diesem Vorsprung rennt die deutsche
Automobilindustrie nun hinterher
es ist nicht damit getan Autos zu bauen
die deutsche Automobilindustrie wird
Elektroautos in Breite für jeden Bedarf
auch anbieten können aber die Menschen
akzeptieren das nur wenn eine Lade
Infrastruktur da ist dass sie das Auto
zu jedem Zeitpunkt an jedem Ort auch
laden können und hier denkt Brüste nicht
weit genug es gibt keine Verpflichtung
für die Mitgliedstaaten die auch
ansatzweise ausreichend ist den
deutschen Autobauern geht die politische
Unterstützung der EU nicht weit genug
wie wird der Strombedarf für die große
Anzahl von E-Autos gedeckt wie kommen
Hersteller krisensicher und unabhängig
von chinesischen Lieferanten an
benötigte Rohstoffe für die Produktion
von Elektroautos wir stehen in einem
globalen harten industriepolitischen
Wettbewerb sowohl in Asien als auch in
Amerika werden die Industrien massiv
unterstützt auch durch staatliche
Zahlungen Stichwort lange Lieferzeiten
in China wo nio produziert sind die kein
Thema mehr man rechnet derzeit mit einer
Lieferung nach zwei oder drei Wochen
dabei ist das Auto in Teilen auch made
in Germany
in München sind die Fahrzeuge gezeichnet
worden das Design ist hier entwickelt
worden wir haben darüber hinaus
Niederlassungen oder Standorte in San
José in den USA wir haben die das Thema
Fahrzeugentwicklung oder Teile davon in
England in Oxford weil die echten
Innovationen im Ausland auf die Straße
gebracht werden könnte Auto Deutschland
in der Ära ohne Verbrennungsmotor den
Anschluss verlieren
und aus Landau in der Pfalz ist uns
jetzt der Bundesverkehrsminister
zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr Wissing
guten Abend Herr Wissing ab 2035 kommt
also das faktische aus für Neuwagen mit
Verbrennermotor in Europa was heißt das
für Menschen die sich in Deutschland in
den nächsten zehn Jahren ein Auto kaufen
wollen
wir stehen jetzt vor großen
transformationsschritten die
Elektromobilität wird eine zentrale
Rolle spielen aber es sind noch nicht
alle Fragen im Zusammenhang mit
klimaneutraler Mobilität beantwortet
deswegen müssen wir auch
technologieoffen bleiben
technologieoffen heißt für Sie dass man
auch e-fuels also synthetische
Kraftstoffe in den Verbrennermotor
einfüllen können soll sie haben rein
verhandelt in den Kompromiss dass das
2026 noch mal geprüft wird warum
weil wir synthetische Kraftstoffe
sogenannte e-fuels brauchen wir haben ja
eine bestandsflotte in Europa die auch
klimaneutral werden muss und es gibt
keinen überzeugenderen Vorschlag als
synthetische Kraftstoffe zu verwenden um
die bestandsflotte klimaneutral zu
betreiben und wir wissen auch noch nicht
welche Rolle synthetische Kraftstoffe
künftig spielen werden deswegen müssen
wir diese Option unbedingt in Europa
sichern wir brauchen jeden Beitrag zur
klimaneutraler Mobilität und nicht die
Verengung nur auf eine Technologie der
ADAC der ja nicht im Verdacht steht den
Grünen nahezustehen sagt das
synthetische Kraftstoffe in der
Herstellung viel zu viel Energie
verbrauchen und ineffizient sind warum
also festhalten daran statt mit voller
Power auf Elektroautos zu setzen
weil wir beispielsweise eine
bestandsflotte haben die auch
klimaneutral werden muss und wir können
ja nicht die Verbrennungsmotoren die
millionenfach in Europa verkauft worden
sind und die auch weiter zugelassen sind
die können wir ja nicht mit elektrischen
Antrieben oder auf elektrische Antriebe
umrüsten deswegen brauchen wir
synthetische Kraftstoffe wir brauchen
sie im Flugverkehr wir brauchen Sie für
schwere Maschinen wir brauchen sie in
der Seeschifffahrt und wir brauchen sie
auch für die bestandsflotte und es ist
ja gar nicht klar zu welchem Preis sie
in Zukunft angeboten werden deswegen
sollte man diese Option als wichtigen
Beitrag zur klimaneutralen Mobilität
nicht einfach beiseite schieben wir
brauchen jede technologische Lösung und
nicht nur einzelne wenn die
Verkehrswende kommen soll dann muss
Deutschland mehr tun damit man
Elektroautos auch wirklich laden kann in
Deutschland kommt auf 711 PKW eine
Ladesäule in den Niederlanden sind es
etwas über 100 warum kommt Deutschland
bei der Säule nicht voran und das ist
das berühmte henna-ei-problem die der
Ausbau muss am Ende schneller gehen als
der Hochlauf der der Elektrofahrzeuge
und deswegen haben wir jetzt im Kabinett
einen Masterplan lade-infrastruktur
verabschiedet mit dem wir ein
deutschland-netz aufbauen
flächendeckend wir brauchen schnell
Ladesäulen entlang unserer Fernstraßen
und wir brauchen natürlich auch in den
Kommunen vor Ort mehr Lademöglichkeiten
mit dem Masterplan den ich vorgelegt
habe den das Kabinett verabschiedet hat
betreiben wir jetzt genau den Ausbau den
wir in Deutschland dringend benötigen
und zwar müssen wir das parallel machen
zum Hochlauf der Elektrofahrzeuge die in
den Markt kommen wir machen das in
Deutschland übrigens mit digitaler
Technologie datenbasiert und sind damit
auch beispielgeben für andere
europäische Länder Deutschland war ja
sehr lange Weltmeister bei den
verbrennermotoren jetzt kommt das aus
und schon haben die
Automobilzulieferer Angst umfasst
300.000 Arbeitsplätze in den nächsten
Jahren was kommt da auf die deutsche
Autoindustrie zu
neues Thema muss man sehr ernst nehmen
deswegen muss die Frage auch offen
bleiben ob der Verbrennungsmotor am Ende
nicht mit synthetischen Kraftstoffen
doch eine Zukunft hat wir wissen auch
dass Elektrofahrzeuge teuer sind und wir
wissen dass Lithium für die Batterien
nicht in unbegrenzter Zahlen zur
Verfügung steht und deswegen macht es
Sinn dass man die Technologie des
Verbrennungsmotors der ja mit
synthetischen Kraftstoffen klimaneutral
betrieben werden kann dass man diese
Technologie offenhält auf etwas ohne Not
zu verzichten wenn so viele
Zukunftsfragen offen sind das ist
fahrlässige Politik deswegen war es uns
auch so wichtig dass wir auf
europäischer Ebene diese Option erhalten
haben
das war der Bundesverkehrsminister
herzlichen Dank mit einem Plädoyer für
die synthetischen Kraftstoffe die noch
weiterlaufen sollen mit zusammen mit der
Elektromobilität herzlichen Dank nach
Landau ich danke Ihnen
und das Interview haben wir am Abend
aufgezeichnet
Zuspitzung ist seine Sache nicht der
Ruck ist es auch nicht Bundespräsident
Frank-Walter Steinmeier wollte sich mit
seiner heutigen Rede an die Nation
zurückmelden obwohl er eigentlich nie
weg war aber die Kritik an ihm war in
den letzten Wochen lauter geworden weil
er sich noch nicht grundsätzlich zum
Krieg in der Ukraine geäußert hatte wer
einen großen Befreiungsschlag erwartet
hatte oder gar Reue des Politikers der
fast 15 Jahre lang für die deutsche
russland-politik verantwortlich war
wurde enttäuscht Klartext gesprochen hat
er trotzdem es kommen raue Zeiten auf
Deutschland zu eine Epoche des
Gegenwinds Patricia Wiedemeier über die
Rede und die Reaktion
lange hatte man auf diese Rede gewartet
lange wurde an ihr gearbeitet heute nun
begann Bundespräsident Steinmeier seine
Rede mit seinen Eindrücken aus der
Ukraine mit seiner Erinnerung an den Tag
des Kriegsbeginns
sie reden
der dunkle Rauch über Kiew die
schrecklichen Bilder dieses morgens
sie gingen und gehen mir unter die Haut
und sie markierten das endgültige
bittere scheitern
jahrelanger politischer Bemühungen auch
meiner
genau diesen schrecklichen Moment zu
verhindern
der 24 Februar war ein Epochenbruch
sich erneut entschuldigen für seine
frühen engen Kontakte zu Russland das
wollte er heute nicht nach seinem Besuch
in Kiew Anfang der Woche dennoch eine
klare Abgrenzung von Russland Putin habe
nicht nur Spielregeln verletzt sondern
die europäische sicherheitsordnung in
Schutt und Asche gelegt wenn wir auf das
Russland von heute schauen
dann ist eben kein Platz für alte Träume
unsere Länder stehen heute gegeneinander
denen die derzeit immer wieder nach
Friedensverhandlungen rufen erteilte er
eine klare Absage niemandem der besinnen
ist fehlt der Wille
aber die Wahrheit ist im Angesicht des
Bösen reicht eben guter Wille nicht aus
unter den Gästen der neue ukrainische
Botschafter der besonders von diesem
Teil der Rede angetan war Töne die man
von seinem Vorgänger Melnik so wohl
nicht gehört hätte für mich persönlich
war es eine Ukraine Rede er hat
Deutschland und durch Mitbürgerinnen und
Mitbürger dazu aufgerufen
zusammen mit der Ukraine zu sein der
Ukraine zu helfen
und eigentlich habe ich mich hier als
Ukrainer und Europäer gefüllt
anschließend hat Steinmeier die
Deutschen auf eine schwierige Zukunft
eingestimmt verlangt von den Bürgern
Einschränkungen und Bescheidenheit es
kommen härtere Jahre
raue Jahre auf uns zu die
Friedensdividende ist aufgezehrt und es
beginnt für Deutschland eine Epoche im
Gegenwind es komme jetzt auf den
Zusammenhalt an Reich und Arm Jung und
Alt Stadt und Land Ost und West zudem
müsse der Kampf gegen den Klimawandel
verstärkt werden ich mache mir ehrlich
gesagt sorgen dass diese
menschheitsaufgabe
zu sehr in den Hintergrund gerät der
Klimawandel macht keine Ukraine Pause
das Echo im Saale durchgehend positiv
für mich war es eine große Rede weil sie
die Begrifflichkeiten gesetzt hat dass
wir jetzt in eine Epoche mit Gegenwind
geraten ich muss sagen ich empfinde es
wirklich als eine historische Rede
zuerst mal habe ich die Räder als sehr
starke Rede wahrgenommen allerdings war
leider von jungen Menschen sehr wenig
die Rede aber war es wirklich eine
historische rede mit dem einen
bleibenden Satz wie bei einigen seiner
Vorgänger der 8 Mai war ein Tag der
Befreiung durch Deutschland muss ein
Ruck gehen unser Herz ist weit aber
unsere Möglichkeiten sind endlich der
Islam gehört inzwischen auch zu
Deutschland nein bei Steinmeier habe das
eigene Schuldeingeständnis im Verhältnis
zu Russland und die Leidenschaft gefehlt
mein Politikwissenschaftlerin römmele
eine inhaltlich sehr gute Rede weil sie
ehrlich war weil die uns auf Gegenwind
eingeschworen hat der kommen wird ob sie
verfängt oder nicht wird die Zeit zeigen
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass sie etwas
mit mehr Pathos gefüllt gewesen wäre
weil sie dann besser angekommen wäre bei
den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern drinnen im
Saale jedoch kam sie ganz gut an alles
zu stärken was uns verbindet das ist die
Aufgabe tun wir es vielen Dank und wer
weiß vielleicht wird es ja dieser letzte
Satz sein der in Erinnerung bleiben wird
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
Gundula und den Nachrichten und die
beginnen mit noch einer Rede und heftige
Kritik die hat CSU-Chef Söder an der
Arbeit der Bundesregierung geübt die
Ampel sei wohl eine der schwächsten
Regierungen die Deutschland je gehabt
haben ein Jahr vor der Landtagswahl in
Bayern sagte er auf dem CSU-Parteitag
die Regierung wirke bei der aktuellen
Energiekrise überfordert Söder
attackierte insbesondere die Grünen
ihr seid keine klimapartei ihr seid die
gleiche alte linke
anti-akkw-partei und es spricht bei euch
immer noch die gleichen Claudia Roth
weint und Trittin schreit das braucht
Deutschland nicht liebe Freunde
ausführlich berichtet später das heute
journal update vom CSU-Parteitag auf dem
Morgen CDU-Chef Merz erwartet wird
Corona ist nach Aussage des Präsidenten
der Ständigen Impfkommission Mertens
mittlerweile eine endemische
Virusinfektion ein Großteil der
Bevölkerung sei inzwischen genesen
geimpft oder beides sagte der Mediziner
den Bayerischen Rundfunk Corona werde
uns wie die Grippe über Generationen
erhalten bleiben es gelte diejenigen zu
schützen die ein Risiko hätten zu
erkranken sei es durch impfen oder das
Tragen von Masken
unbekannte haben einen Brandanschlag auf
eine geplante Flüchtlingsunterkunft in
Bautzen verübt das Feuer war
ausgebrochen nachdem Fenster eingeworfen
worden waren vier Menschen die in dem
Gebäude übernachteten blieben unverletzt
Sachsens Innenminister Schuster sprach
von einem fremdenfeindlichen
Brandanschlag das Landeskriminalamt
prüft einen möglichen politischen
Hintergrund
im Iran dauern die Proteste gegen die
Regierung an trotz des weiterhin
gewaltsamen Vorgehens der Polizei
mehreren Berichten zufolge sollen in
sachedan Sicherheitskräfte auf
demonstrierende geschossen haben dort
ist jetzt der Polizei-Chef entlassen
worden er soll ebenso wie geistliche in
der Region Kritik an der harten Haltung
des der Regierung des Regimes geübt
haben
die demokratische Vorsitzende des
US-Repräsentantenhauses war offenbar
Ziel einer Attacke gewesen in ihrer
Abwesenheit wurde in ihr Wohnhaus in San
Francisco eingebrochen ihr Ehemann dort
angegriffen und verletzt der Einbrecher
wurde festgenommen die Hintergründe sind
noch unklar
die Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
IAEA will noch in dieser Woche
Inspektoren in die umkraine schicken
Experten sollen dort die Vorwürfe
Russlands überprüfen die Ukraine plane
den Einsatz einer schmutzigen Bombe mit
radioaktiven Material
IAEA-Chef grossy erklärte die
Beobachtermission werde an zwei
Standorten Kontrollen durchführen die
Ukraine und Russland hatten sich zuvor
für die Prüfung ausgesprochen
und wir gehen in die Ukraine die
russische Armee greift das Land
weiterhin Tag und Nacht mit Drohnen und
Raketen an Russlands einzige Taktik sei
der Terror sagte der ukrainische
Präsident wollladimir selenski in seiner
nächtlichen Videobotschaft und dennoch
kehren ukrainische Familien zurück ins
Kriegsgebiet weil sie die Trennung von
Vätern Brüdern und ihrem Zuhause nur
schwer aushalten unsere Reporter daran
hat in Odessa Rückkehrer Familie
getroffen und sie in ihre noch immer
umkämpfte Heimatstadt Nikolajew
begleitet
nur deshalb treffen wir Familie
littowitsch ihre Fröhlichkeit steckt an
und überrascht denn sie haben einiges
hinter sich sechs Monate war die Familie
getrennt als Mutter Julia und Sohn Juri
Anfang März über Moldawien nach
Deutschland geflüchtet sind
das Schuljahr hat der Online beendet und
sogar Deutsch gelernt zumindest ein
bisschen
jetzt wollen sie ein neues Leben in
Odessa aufbauen mitten im Krieg Juri
träumt davon Regisseur von
Animationsfilmen zu werden er animiert
Bilder gemalt von traumatisierten
Flüchtlingskindern aus der Ukraine
Kinder sehen das alles doch aus ihrer
Perspektive mit ihren Augen sie malen
zum Beispiel wütende Panzer
[Musik]
Kinderbilder lernen plötzlich laufen die
Idee geht auf eine ehemalige Nachbarin
zurück eine Kinderpsychologin die sich
um traumatisierte ukrainische Kinder
kümmert wie ein Märchen sei die Zeit als
Flüchtling in Deutschland gewesen sagt
Juri die liebsten Menschen der Welt
hätten sie aufgenommen und sie würden
wohl bis heute nicht verstehen weshalb
er und seine Mutter zurück wollten in
ein Land im Krieg
und Juri hat nicht verstanden warum die
Deutschen sich so sorgen so viel Angst
haben
solltet in die Ukraine kommen dann
würdet ihr erleben wie man ohne Angst
lebt
oder das Gegenteil erleben was wahre
Angst bedeutet
erstmals seit ihrer Flucht kehren sie
nach Nikolajew zurück wo Juri bis
Kriegsbeginn aufgewachsen ist die Stadt
des täglich unter Beschuss auch ihr Haus
wurde getroffen erstmals wollen Sie mit
eigenen Augen sehen was von ihrem Heim
geblieben ist
nur ein Fenster ist noch ganz ein
Schrapnell hat das Haus getroffen so
sehr sie es sich wünschen solange
nicolajevin Reichweite russische
Artillerie liegt macht es keinen Sinn
juris Elternhaus wieder entstand zu
setzen
es scheint als sei alles in Ordnung die
Küche die Zimmer das Treppenhaus aber es
gibt keinen Strom kein Wasser und keine
Fenster mehr am Anfang dachte ich meine
Katze würde rauskommen aber hier wohnt
niemand mehr gut
Joris Elternhaus so viele Jahre war es
mit Leben gefüllt ihrem Leben jetzt ist
es leer es gleicht einem Geisterhaus
Elon Musk ist ein genialer Unternehmer
mit einem riesen Ego der erfolgreiche
tesla-fabrikant und SpaceX Raketenbauer
neigt nicht zu Bescheidenheit und so
begründete der amerikanische Milliardär
den Kauf des Kurznachrichtendienstes
Twitter mit den Worten ich tat es um der
Menschheit zu helfen die ich liebe
twitter ist allerdings ein Medium das
häufiger durch Hass als durch Liebe
aufgefallen ist und die Frage ist nun
was der Exzentriker mask mit der
Plattform vorhat die Befürchtung ist
dass er die Grenzen des Sagbaren weiter
ausdehnen könnte wenn Jamin Daniel
berichtet aus Washington
als Elon Musk am frühen Morgen twittert
der Vogel sei freigelassen worden ließ
die Reaktion der EU nicht lange auf sich
warten so antwortete EU-Kommissar
Thierry Britton umgehend mit den Worten
in Europa wird der Vogel nach unseren
EU-Regeln fliegen
bereitet mir eine gewisse Schadenfreude
das Elon Musk darauf eingehen muss er
muss der EU Antworten und es wird
interessant sein zu sehen ob seine
wild-west-ansichten vereinbar sind mit
der eher konservativen eu-auffassung
wenn es um Regeln für freie Rede im
Internet geht
bereits gestern hatte Musk seine
Profilbeschreibung in chief Twitch
geändert der Chef Twitterer oder
wörtlich übersetzt der Chef Trottel Musk
liebt solche Zweideutigkeiten eindeutig
hingegen ist nun nach langem hin und her
sein Kauf der Social Media Plattform auf
der er folgendes postete
ich habe Twitter gekauft weil es wichtig
für die Zukunft unserer Zivilisation ist
einen gemeinsamen digitalen Marktplatz
zu haben auf dem viele Überzeugungen auf
gesunde Art und Weise diskutiert werden
können ohne dass es in Gewalt mündet
Rückblick Ende April sagt der tesla-chef
den Kauf des Konzerns für 44 Milliarden
Dollar zu dann will er den Deal wieder
abblasen Twitter klagt und noch vor
Prozessbeginn schließen die Parteien nun
doch den Kauf ab als erster Amtshandlung
feuert mask prompt mehrere Top-Manager
wie den bisherigen Firmenchef den
Finanzchef und die Chef justitiain der
reichste Mensch der Welt ist also nun
Besitzer einer der Reichweiten stärksten
Plattformen das halten viele für
gefährlich denn mask hat häufig betont
die Leitplanken der Redefreiheit
deutlich erweitern zu wollen
er glaubt fest an das was er unter
Redefreiheit versteht dass weniger
Moderation der Post stattfinden sollte
und weniger Inhalte gelöscht werden
sollten die Falschinformationen
verbreiten es könnte also einen riesigen
Einfluss auf Twitters Rolle unserer
Gesellschaft haben
die Übernahme hat natürlich auch eine
politische Dimension so hat Musk
beispielsweise angekündigt das Konto
Donald Trumps wieder entsperren zu
wollen und es gibt noch weitere Aspekte
die Beobachtern Sorge bereiten mask
Sames wirkt unglaublich naiv wenn es um
Außenpolitik geht ständig macht er
irgendwelche Vorschläge die für
Außenpolitik Experten überhaupt keinen
Sinn ergeben manchmal würden sie auch
Russland oder China begünstigen Musk hat
eine große Fabrik in Shanghai also es
gibt Grund zur Sorge dass er seine
politischen Überzeugungen mit seinem
unternehmerischen Interesse vermischt
Hills pretical stands with his
commercial interest es ist also ein Deal
der in vielerlei Hinsicht riesige Wellen
schlägt da Twitter nun in Privathand ist
hat die New Yorker Börse die Aktien auch
bereits aus dem Handel genommen
das ist so die Aktien sind in New York
aus dem Handel genommen worden und auch
die anderen Tag Giganten belasten die
Finanzmärkte die Aktien von Meta Amazon
und Google verlieren stark Frank bedmann
selbst die us-tag-werte können sich also
nicht gegen schwache Märkte stemmen ja
es ist eine Woche zum Vergessen für das
bis dato für die bis dato stets
gefeierten
Technologiekonzerne dreistellige
Milliardensummen lösen sich in Luft auf
weil die Aktienkurse Abstürzen zunächst
die von Microsoft und vom Google
Mutterkonzern Alphabet am schlimmsten
aber erwischt es die
facebook-dachgesellschaft Meter das
suckerberg Imperium verliert in nur drei
Tagen rund 30 Prozent an Börsenwert und
die Papiere von Amazon geben seit
gestern in der Spitze bis zu 20 Prozent
nach auslöser dieses börsenbebens sind
überwiegend schlechte Geschäftszahlen in
Kombination und das ist noch
entscheidender mit trüben Ausblicken
sowohl bei Alphabet und Microsoft als
auch bei Amazon der weltgrößte
Online-Händler Fundament enttäuscht
senkt die Erwartungen fürs
Weihnachtsgeschäft deutlich ungewohnte
Töne sowas kannte man von dem
wachstumsstarken US-Konzern bislang
nicht aber auch Amazon spürt inzwischen
Inflation und Rezessionssorgen genauso
wie Apple das iPhone der Umsatzbringer
schlechthin schwächelt auch der Konzern
mit dem Apfel warnt inzwischen vor
Umsatzrückgängen im laufenden Quartal
noch aber kommt Apple bei den Anlegern
vergleichsweise gut weg
vielen Dank Frank
nachzutragen ist dass die deutsche
Wirtschaft im dritten Quartal
überraschend zugelegt hat trotz aller
Krisen um 0,3% Punkte gegenüber dem vor
Quartal so eine erste Schätzung des
Statistischen Bundesamtes Sorgen
bereitet vor allem die hohe Inflation
die von zehn Prozent im September auf
10,4 Prozent im Oktober gestiegen ist
ein neuer Höchststand im Tarifkonflikt
der deutschen Metall- und
Elektroindustrie hat die Gewerkschaft IG
Metall ab Mitternacht zu Warnstreiks in
ausgewählten Betrieben aufgerufen das
Angebot der Arbeitgeber 3000 Euro
steuerfreie Einmalzahlung plus ein noch
nicht festgelegtes Lohnplus über 30
Monate hatten mehrere Bezirke der
Gewerkschaft abgelehnt sie fordern eine
Lohnerhöhung von 8% über ein Jahr
zum Fußball in der Bundesliga hat der
zwölfte Spieltag begonnen mit der Partie
Werder Bremen gegen Hertha BSC am Abend
das Spiel ist gerade eben zu Ende
gegangen mit einem Sieg der Gastgeber 1
zu 0 für Werder Bremen
eine der größten Legenden des
amerikanischen Rock'n'Roll ist gestorben
the killer wie Jerry Lee Lewis sich
selbst nannte wurde 87 Jahre alt für
Furore sorgte Lewis auf der Bühne mit
seinem schnellen und körperbetonten
Klavierspiel in den 50er Jahren landete
er seinen größten Hit great balls of
Fire wilde Auftritte führten zum Image
eines Bad Boys aber auch eines der
letzten Rock n Roller alter Schule
[Musik]
das war's das war es von uns an diesem
Freitagabend gleich geht's hier weiter
mit Oliver Welke und der heute-show und
0.15 ist hier wieder Zeit für das heute
journal Update mit Anna Zimmermann und
uns gibt es morgen wieder wenn Sie mögen
schönen Abend und tschüss
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter ja zur
Einordnung des heutigen Tages starten
wir mal mit den aktuellen
oktoberrekorden und das sind bei den
Tageshöchstwerten 30,9 Grad in Mülheim
in Baden-Württemberg die mildeste
Oktober Nacht gab es in Wernigerode im
Harz mit 20,5 Grad und diese Rekorde die
haben wir heute nicht geknackt aber es
gab in Mülheim mit 28,7 Grad immerhin
den höchsten Wert für die letzten 10
Oktobertage also ein dekadenrekord und
auf unsere Top 5 Liste Folgen Freiburg
Emmendingen Buchenbach allesamt in
Baden-Württemberg und gasebach in
Sachsen mit deutlich über 25 Grad und
insgesamt wurden an mehr als 25
Stationen heute in Deutschland ein
Sommertag registriert die kommende Nacht
die ist jetzt nicht mehr ganz so mild
wie die vergangene da hatten wir in Bad
Harzburg 19,9 Grad aber auch in dieser
Nacht sind wir meist zweistellig nur im
Südosten da sinken die Werte auf 7 Grad
hier ist es auch oft klar da bildet sich
dann Nebel sonst ist es Kind bis stark
bewölkt und auch morgen haben wir diese
starke Bewölkung im Norden anfangs noch
in der Mitte da gibt es auch mal etwas
Regen die meiste Sonne sehen wir im
Süden und am Nordrand der Gebirge und
das ist der Föhn der sich da mit
schwachem Südwind auch heute schon
eingestellt hat und bei den Tages
Höchstwerten so deutlich mithilft so
dass die morgen im ledergebirge und im
Südwesten wieder auf 26 Grad steigen im
Norden und im Nebel ist es deutlich
kühler aber immer noch zu mild und auch
der Sonntag ist mild und sonnig erst zum
Beginn der neuen Woche gehen die
Temperaturen langsam zurück